let's ask michael schellenberger
president of environmental progress and
author of apocalypse never
mike is this coming i mean a lot of
people are saying and wall street this
could be coming
yeah thanks for having me on jesse i
mean you just described it really well
which is that the dilemma for policy
makers is do you buy russian oil
and and finance their war in the ukraine
or do you not buy it and then see a
pretty sharp increase in oil prices i
mean it could go up to 200 a barrel if
that happens then there's very
significant risk of recession we could
be seeing energy electricity and food
shortages before the end of the year
that's that's very bad situation that's
why policymakers like biden are
reluctant to do that in fact we may see
biden impose
restrictions on u.s oil exports but then
that would would strengthen the hand of
putin in order to use oil and gas to
basically bribe countries
to let him have his way so
the underlying problem is when you said
we just haven't had enough supply we
should have been producing much more oil
and gas over the last five years
i and others over the last week have
been pointing out the fact that it was
the secretary general of nato himself
who pointed out that russia was
financing
anti-gas fracking activist groups in
europe which had basically prevented
europe from developing its own natural
gas
15 years ago europe produced more
natural gas than russia today russia
produces three times more natural gas
than than europe consumes so it's it's
really been a pro a product of this
pro-scarcity
pro-renewables anti-natural gas
anti-nuclear movement in europe that
allowed putin to be able to wield the
power that he's wielding
you're saying that russian
money was funding disinformation and
green campaigns in europe to get them to
get off of natural gas get them to stop
fracking scare them out of fracking do
you think they're financing that type of
disinformation campaign here do you
think the greens in america are taking
dirty russian money to scare americans
out of fracking and
energy exploration in this country
well there was some research into this i
have looked into it to some extent it's
hard for me to say one way or another i
haven't really seen the proof of it but
you had both the secretary of general of
nato and secretary of state hillary
clinton both confirming that russians
were funding
anti-natural gas fracking activity
activities in europe you know shale
which is where we get a lot of our oil
and gas from the united states exists in
europe too there's a big shale in great
britain that they have not tapped for
its oil and gas but you just saw an
overall repression of oil and gas
exploration
in europe and around the world due to
climate activists but the consequence is
that we're actually using more coal this
year than we did in past years and of
course we're at the risk of a very you
know as you said the worst energy crisis
since 1973 is a strong possibility as is
the risk of recession because that's
what happens every time there's a big
increase in oil prices yeah and the
germans just came out today and said
we're gonna we're gonna start burning a
lot of coal they go i don't care about
the politics i'm a green guy i'm a green
socialist we're gonna burn coal because
that's pragmatic and right now we need
action we don't need ideology and if the
germans think like that
why can't joe biden i don't i don't get
it michael shellenberger thank you so
much